hi I'm Lucy and I'm Dave and we've been
playing some of homefront revolutions
co-op visa so Dave you play the original
game yep initial thoughts on how it's
different well the original homefront
was a very linear experience home for
the revolution is now gone open world
and it's kept its core FBS roots but now
there's a lot of RPG elements to it
which i think is something we're seeing
quite a lot in shooters these days yeah
like division was it yeah so I mean
starting off when you play in corvallis
you get to choose a backstory for your
character which of course have different
trades so I picked dancer so I was more
agile and nimble on the battlefield what
were you I was a little street urchin so
as so my scavenging was a little bit
bare so as soon as I was murdering
people hand them down four bullets full
of ammo so it's quite it's quite nifty
and its weight and I said differentiated
it helps it because you have skill
points that you build up throughout a
game I you know so here dancer you've
got a little bit more in movement and it
kind of builds up throughout your
experience which is quite fun yeah so
like if you chose medic at the start you
could put more points into your medic
skill tree then you become more useful
to your allies so it's a real subtle way
to change the game play experience I
think another thing I noticed is that
there is a lot of customization yeah in
terms of weaponry your skill trees ER
calls automatics cosmetics and the way
they do that is you can unlock stuff
through general progression but it's
mostly done through card packs neujahr
bang on trend right yeah that's maybe
another hot thing that I ain't doing hot
hot new thing in your honest so you can
you earn in-game money by playing all
you can spend them real world fun bucks
to buy packs yeah and that dictates what
cosmetics you get what weapon
attachments you get so it literally
everything is attainable through these
packs they made a real big statement
that it was not paid to win and you can
actually decide what kind of things you
want to unlock with all packs if you
want heavy weapons in ordnance
ordnance pack so it is it is a little
bit luck of the draw for what you get
but from what we played I think I think
they've structured an interesting
balance so in terms of gameplay itself
you are very much the underdog yeah in
home from the revolution the basic story
is Korea reunites and takes out the US
and the Korean People's Army are way
more powerful they have been a
technology better weaponry and the USA
reduced to kind of scrabbling around so
your resistance cells are hugely the
underdogs your supply is very limited
you get outnumbered really easily and
you really are the minority that are an
uprising so the tactics that you and
start investing in it is very much
guerrilla warfare hit-and-run tactics
you go take one objective and you
actually have to bug out of there real
fast because you've got the might of the
Korean People's Army dooming down on you
and that's the thing because I didn't
think the missions themselves were
particularly those stuff you done before
you know go here take out these typos
pack these ports by standing next to
them it was typical stuff that we've
seen before but the fact that you were
so underpowered and you did have to hit
and run you did I mean we played levels
where you had run out of stuff and the
rest of us were just trying to get their
attention while you could Scrabble
around and get stuff to craft on the fly
a bomb to take out this tank it did make
it feel different and it didn't and it
was quite nice to not be that over
powerful yeah like one man army and you
did have to work together yeah I think
that's really what my main feeling of
home front is that it's very core and
its backbone is everything we've seen
before in a shooter but the things that
they've added to it the underdog element
the crafting I think that sets itself
out from all the other shooters we play
which i think is a very admirable trait
in this day and age and I think that
makes it interesting enough to invest
some time in and on top of that there is
a whole year of free DLC no season pass
so even if you kind of get bored there
is stuff to keep coming back to
yeah there's a lot of a lot of America
to defend so it's good that it's
hopefully got a good life span to it
home from the revolution is out in May
for the latest make sure you keep it
gamespot
I